did you pray sir see how I caught you
there you've got an hour left my brother
and my sister pray no matter what's
happening in your life pray no matter
what sin you're committing and how much
of it you committing pray no excuses
sister tells me brother I don't wear
hijab I tell you pray she tells me
looking at my dress code is not the best
I tell you pray brother I drink alcohol
pray brother tells me I sell drugs pray
I take drugs pray I have a girlfriend
and I'm sleeping with her I tell you
pray no matter what's happening in your
life pray but brother how can I be
committing all of these sins and pray
that's disrespectful or that makes me a
hypocrite
I tell you no that's why we pray because
we're not perfect we're sinners we do
wrong pray Allah says the prayer will
take you away from seen pray you know
sometimes people say look let me
straighten my life out and in Cheryl I'm
gonna start praying hey baby you will
never straight in anything if you don't
pray that's why you pray just straight
in your life felt nothing my brothers
and sisters let no men get between you
and Allah pray no matter what's
happening in your life pray no matter
where you are
pray you know sometimes people come to
you and tell you brother or sister
you're a hypocrite
sister you know you know where the jab
and you pray tell a sister thank you
very much I'm a hypocrite my last panel
up I'll reward you but my prayers
between me and Allah no one else's
business the prophet of Allah is the
difference between us and them is the
prey the very first question on the day
of resurrection that you're going to be
asked is about the pray if you pass then
everything after that's going to be easy
but if you fail that then everything
after that is just gonna get worse so I
pray pray my brothers you will earn a
mother's love pray and you will earn His
mercy and His forgiveness
imagine your friend is Allah we ask
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to make us of
those who establish they pray and never
leave it no matter what